manifestantes furiosos salieron a las
calles de manila cuando los resultados
de las elecciones revelaron la victoria
no oficial de ferdinand marcos júnior
que se convertirá en el próximo
presidente de filipinas y podrían haber
sido la gente aquí no lo acepta no creo
que nunca lo acepten están aquí para
expresar un profundo sentimiento de
indignación por el sistema político de
filipinas que ha permitido que el
heredero del dictador marcos vuelva al
poder como presidente marcos
apodado bombón marcos juniors aplastó a
su rival en y robredo para convertirse
en el primer candidato presidencial en
la historia reciente del país en ganar
con una mayoría absoluta pero los
críticos dicen que su campaña estuvo
marcada por el blanqueo de la notoria
dinastía de su familia y muchos temen
que su liderazgo refleje la brutal y
corrupta dictadura de su padre las
peticiones para descalificar al
candidato de 64 años fueron desestimadas
por el organismo electoral filipino
a ver estoy muy asustada y muy muy
decepcionado de que esto esté ocurriendo
en mi país ahora mismo nunca en mi vida
pensé que viviría otra presidencia de
marcos esto es muy deprimente
sinceramente
por su parte marcos juniors ha prometido
trabajar para el pueblo y ha pedido que
se le juzgue por su presidencia y no por
el pasado de su familia su compañera de
fórmula es sara duterte hija del
presidente saliente rodrigo duterte
quien a pesar de su gobierno autoritario
conserva un amplio apoyo el ganador de
los comicios tomará posesión del cargo a
finales de junio para un mandato único
de seis años